Avengers infinity war left a lot of
dangling questions among the most
important well as the Hulk the big green
guy orbit abandoned the Bruce Banner in
the battle against Thanos was his
absence just build up for an endgame
triumph it's a good bet that he'll be
back in the big infinity saga finale
which makes us ask one big question
could a vengeful Hulk actually put
Thanos to bed permanently here's all the
ways we think that might happen one of
the most defining elements of the Hulk
is that the mean green brute is strong
really really strong there are so many
layers of pure unadulterated muscle that
it has always been a primary trait over
the decades whether it be on the printed
page television sets or cinematic
universe after all the hoax the best sir
is at what he does and what he does is
well at this point everyone knows that
if you hit Hogg hard you're only going
to be hit back harder of course this
natural ability to muscle up but makes
Hulk a prime choice to use in any kind
of one-on-one showdown if Hulk starts
smashing you can bet there's a fair
chance that Thanos systemize might occur
under those two giant green fists but of
course the question that naturally
arises from that statement is whether
he'll start smashing in the first place
the biggest mystery about the Hulk when
it comes to infinity war is just where
he was during the whole ordeal when push
came to shove with the universe at stake
Hulk was a non-starter
he had a peek around that took a few
lumps from Thanos and call it quits
quicker than anyone else in the film of
course that doesn't mean Hulk was really
done anyone who watches that opening
scene can pretty quickly see that the
Jade giant wasn't quite in character
he looks dazed confused and half
committed it turns out according to the
Russos themselves Hulk wasn't so much
scared by the confrontation as genuinely
angry about her director Joe Russo
stated plainly on the commentary track
people have speculated whether there was
some fear and the Hulk's part about
having a face Stannis again but I think
ultimately what it is is that he's tired
of playing hero to Bruce Banner and
after two years spent in control of
soccer can you blame him if hoaxes go in
to stop Thanos he's going to need to get
over his hurt feelings and take the
reins once again of course hogg
substance actually plays nicely into his
chances of dealing the final blow to the
mad Titan as of
of infinity war Thanos sees the Hulk as
nothing more than a passing annoyance
his attention an endgame will probably
be more focused on characters like Thor
who've already stabbed him in the chest
and Captain Marvel who's been confirmed
to be the most powerful superhero in the
MCU this could play into the Avengers
hands nicely as everyone else knows that
Hulk really is one of their best chances
at beating the living daylights out of
Thanos perhaps rather than a straight-up
brawl it'll be the elements of surprise
that could help the Hulk rise to the
occasion and be the one to take down
Thanos once Hulk gets over his hurt
feelings he won't feel the twinge of
embarrassment or having left everyone to
fend for themselves during what was
clearly the largest crisis that the
Avengers have ever faced if he really
did sits out because he was being a baby
about the whole losing control issue
once he has a chance to process things
with Banner he might even feel a little
remorse and regret at how everything
went down plus the fact that he was made
to look like a fool could give Hulk a
healthy dose of inspiration not to
mention a vendetta against a guy who
made him look like an idiot while he was
taking a timeout before we move on to
more specific ways that Hulk could take
down Thanos let's talk about one more
big picture element that could factor in
here Hulk is strong sure but honestly
he's not the only member on the team
that can go toe-to-toe with Thanos and
have a fighting chance even Iron Man got
him to bleed a little right rule that
true drop of blood but one thing the
Hulk has that he gathers don't is the
exponential scaling of his rage
Hulk literally thrives in adversity if
he feels outmatched he gets angry and
his trance scales along with her he's
virtually untouched by fear too if the
green Goliath can get angry early enough
in a fight with fanos there's a good
chance the mad Titan side of that
equation is going to have a rough go of
her while the thoughts of a furious Hulk
her giving Thanos a run for his money is
as good as gold there's one weapon that
hope could use that wouldn't make the
entire affair that much better for a
while now it's been heavily rumoured
that Tony Stark's part and the end game
of endgame involves him reassembling the
Avengers and building his own infinity
gauntlets
another rumor indicated that it might be
none other than the Hulk who wills the
second gauntlet in battle against Thanos
the theory even comes of the added
speculation that Hulk may end up losing
an arm in the process whether he loses
an arm or not though the simple fact
that Hulk could end up wielding the
Infinity stones could give him all the
power
to kill thanos while it's fun to think
up Hulk smash scenarios that could lead
to fellow systemize the truth is after
infinity war that seems to be something
of a Hulk special being cooked up at
Marvel Studios a while back actor Mark
Ruffalo explained that the Hulk at a
story arc taking place over the course
of three separate movies Thor Ragnarok
Avengers infinity war and Avengers and
game this led to a bunch of rumors that
points to the idea that hope story may
actually end in reconciliation between
himself and Bruce Banner a burying of
the hatchet between the two could
finally pave the way for the arrival of
Professor Hulk a version of the
character who has the brains of banner
and the Brawn of the Hulk I hope that's
a smart as he is strong could be just a
hero to finally take down Thanos
speaking of Professor Hulk even if we're
fairly certain about his appearance in
endgame Marvel Studios has been
tight-lipped about how to synthesize
character could actually appear and of
course whenever Marvel is reticent about
something the fans are ready to step up
to the plate one particularly
interesting theory about the
transformation actually involves ancient
one Tilda Swinton's character and Doctor
Strange the theory suggests that banner
will head back in time along with
everyone else via the quantum realm once
there he'll cross paths with the ancient
one who will help teach him how to
control his anger and bring about the
healing that the two so desperately need
there's some evidence to support it -
Mark Ruffalo did refer to working with
Swinton in an unnamed project in 2017
the ancient one has also been reported
to be among the action figures being
made for endgame so it's certainly
possible well there's no doubt that Hulk
is a top contender to take Thanos down
he's certainly not the only option on
the table in fact there are quite a few
other people who are actively standing
in line in front of him the guilt Laden
Tony Stark has a laundry list of reasons
to be the guy who takes a kill shot
nebulus list might even be longer at
this point and besides she was critical
in toppling Thanos and the Infinity
Gauntlet comics Thor is just plain angry
about everything at this point and wants
some revenge somewhere but even if
someone else actually kills Sano's whole
could be an instrumental piece of that
scenarios simply by being a distraction
how often did the Avengers get the
important stuff done while Hulk is busy
doing the dirty work in the Battle of
New York cap led the team and I a man
saved everyone's butts by dealing with
the nuke the Hulk is the point man
taking down alien hordes right and left
in a spectacle that drew a ton of
attention and Hulk smash
he's done the same in numerous other
battles if his ultimate role is to play
the distractor he'd know the part
backward and forward by now another way
that Hulk could ultimately kill Thanos
might be by simply stepping aside and
letting Bruce Banner do the work for him
while he may have been dodging his
responsibilities in infinity war getting
the Hulk to come out and play isn't
necessarily the key to everything going
well in fact puny Bruce Banner may have
a much more important part to play than
we think 1 heavily rumored element that
could be critical in endgame is the
aforementioned time-travel via the
quantum realm the problem is who's going
to be able to help everyone move back
and forth through time Scott Lang has
the experience but he's lacking the
scientific know-how sure he might be
able to do it but based on what we've
seen in the endgame trailer she's fallen
victim to Thanos his snap at the end of
the day having someone like Bruce Banner
on hand to guide the team through the
quantum realm could be just the brainy
ticket the team needs to take Thanos
down
we've spent a good amount of time
breaking down hogs furious rage and how
it could be a factor but one popular
theory is that we'll get to see world
breaker Hulk who is world breaker Hulk
in essence it's the strongest
manifestation of hope that we've ever
gotten to see in the comic books and
certainly one that could give Thanos a
run for his money with or without his
fancy pants Infinity Gauntlet one
popular fan theory pointed out that the
timing would be pretty fitting Thora's
pretty much finishes evolution into a
nearly or powerful being for Hulk is
lagging behind and due for a story arc
finale and as we know Avengers endgame
represents the end of the arc that Mark
Ruffalo was discussed in interviews in
the past perhaps the stars are aligning
for world break a Hulk to take on Thanos
and reverse the results of their first
meeting whether it's due to his strength
his fury a second Infinity Gauntlet or
anything else
Hulk needs to have one more critical
factor going in his favor if he's going
to top all the mad Titan he needs to
have an interest Hulk's carefree
attitude to ortho knows has crippled his
ability to have any positive impact on
the storyline on the contrary his
actions seem to have simply allowed the
universe to go to hell in a handbasket
no matter how many Captain Marvel's or
ant men show up to try and save the day
in endgame Hulk is going to need to get
his act together in the big Avengers
finale he has to get over any petty
squabbles with banner and team up to
focus on the true danger at hand
both characters have serious upsides
especially
if they're working together oh and
banners probably going to need to get
angry
amazing check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Avengers and game are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]